[Musik]
der erste kaffeefilter mit filterpapier
erfunden von melitta bentz 1908
eingetragen beim patentamt der melitta
kaffee fehlte revolutioniert das
kaffeekochen und wird zum welterfolg die
erfinderin die 35-jährige hausfrau
melitta bentz aus dresden gründet ein
unternehmen gemeinsam mit ihrem mann
produziert sie in heimarbeit die ersten
täter aufgrund der großen nachfrage
beziehen sie bald eigene größere fabrik
räume und stellen mitarbeiter ein
der enkel der firmengründerin thomas
benz erklärt wie seine großmutter auf
die erfindung kann sachsen tanken schon
damals evi kaffee und der kaffee wurde
traditionsgemäß aufgebrüht es wurde also
kaffeekanne gegeben was er drauf und
aufgekocht mit der folge dass man
natürlich kaffeesatz krümel in der
tasche hatte das gefühl meiner
großmutter nicht und sie kann eben eines
tages auf die idee das berühmte
löschblatt ihres sohnes in einen topf zu
integrieren und dann wird ein
filtersystem richard aus messing wird
aluminium und später porzellan aus dem
ursprünglich runden filter mit filter
blatt wird eine tritt derartige
papiertüte mit dem passenden filter die
form ist bis heute unverändert
es wurde befördert dass auch ein
interessanter gedanke der heute nicht
mehr so die große rolle spielt unter dem
gesichtspunkt praktikabilität und
hygiene in der küche
das waren wahrscheinlich die drei
wesentliche danken die damals attraktiv
waren für die hausfrau
denn jetzt wird das kaffeepulver in eine
papiertüte gefüllt die den kaffeesatz
auffängt
anschließend wird die filtertüte
entsorgt das unkomplizierte verfahren
ist schnell beliebt war den
kaffeetrinkern in den 1960 er jahren
beginnt das unternehmen neben hunt
filtern auch elektrische kaffeemaschinen
herzustellen
gleichzeitig wird kontinuierlich an der
verbesserung der filtertüten gearbeitet
immer wieder werden verschiedene
papiersorten getestet der prozess ist
relativ dick und es ist durchlässig für
wasser hält aber aufgrund der größe der
pore neben kaffee mehl fein gemahlenes
kaffeemehl zurück die genaue
beschaffenheit der original melitta
filtertüte ist betriebsgeheimnis
die melitta unternehmensgruppe bands kg
in minden ist mittlerweile ein
internationales unternehmen mit rund
4000 beschäftigten heute macht die
produktion von filtertüten beim militär
nur noch einen kleinen teil des
gesamtumsatzes aus aber die filtertüte
bleibt das erkennungszeichen des hauses
kaffee sorten mit besonders feinen
aromen lassen sich besser als
filterkaffee genießen
peter prüfer fahren als drucklose prüfer
fahren hat sehr viele vorteile die oft
vielleicht gar nicht so beachtet werden
sie müssen bedenken dass durch dieses
prüfverfahren gerade feiner und sehr
zart entwickelte aromen der kaffeebohne
sehr sehr gut herausgearbeitet werden
können weltweit nimmt der gefilterte
genuss wieder zu immer mehr cafés in
deutschland bieten neben espresso und
cappuccino auch filterkaffee an
filterkaffee ist irgendwo die reine form
kaffee genießen zu können oder zu zu zum
zubereiten dass es durch das besondere
im filter gewinn
und so wird der kaffeefilter auch
weiterhin eingesetzt
dank der kreativen hausfrau
erfinderinnen und unternehmerinnen
melitta bentz